Peter King here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Peter everything is going
great thank you what was it like in the
aftermath you're always right there in
the middle walk me through what you did
well
obviously went into I was taping some
stuff for a podcast I heard of an
instant podcast so interesting okay I
got I got Frank Reich alone for five
minutes I got Josh McDaniels alone got
Trey Burton alone so I got Jeff Lurie so
I got a few people and I've got a fun
little podcast up at the mm QB right but
mostly you know rich in these
circumstances I find more than honestly
more than like talking to people with my
notebook out I'm more curious to find
out to just observe what happens in the
locker room the pure joy in the Eagles
locker room was was really special when
you have Malcolm Jenkins on you got to
ask him about his you know you had
everybody around him and he was talking
to them after the game and it's very
very rare that you know 10 or 15
reporters are on the edge of the group
listening because the locker room by
that point is open so we got to hear
Doug Peterson talking to his team
Malcolm Jenkins and that was kind of
cool but the thing that that I really
enjoyed doing after this game is kind of
sluicing a little bit because Frank
Wright told me that this assistant coach
who nobody's ever heard of this
assistant quarterback coach named pres
Taylor basically has this Bank of trick
plays that he keeps that he keeps track
of and that he has an extensive file of
and so press Taylor basically you know
in the minnesota chicago game into one
of the minnesota chicago games in 2015
basically saw the display that was the
play of the Super Bowl
you know the Trey Burton pass to Nick
Foles
and so then I had to go up and find it
in my some one of my writers at the mm
QB Kalin Caylor was with me up in the
press box and so I said to were
basically hey fight in this play so she
actually found it on NFL game past week
17 2015 clay Meredith basically you know
takes the pitch in the Bears backfield
and Matt Barkley runs exactly the route
that Nick Foles read and there we are
it's like 2:15 in the morning and I feel
like high-fiving and husband Palin
because she found it she found the play
at 2:15 and that became a really big
piece of my Monday Morning Quarterback
column and it's those it's those little
discoveries that just you know by that
time of the day you're pretty tired sure
your energy just gets you so fired up at
that point that you know you could be up
for another six hours that that really
sort of drives you but that was sort of
my favorite thing and spending five
minutes with Doug Peterson way in the
bowels of their locker room alone just
me and him and him basically saying that
hey listen coaching conservative is a
recipe for going eight Nate no doubt
that was it was all that fun locker room
I saw that Peter I saw that it is it is
a great recipe or certainly in the Super
Bowl
it's against Belichick and Brady or
against an offense that's going off I
thought the fourth down play called in
the first half and then that fourth down
play call with five and change to go to
go for it right that's up there with the
Sean Payton onside kick to start the
second half of the same Super Bowl
victory that goes up there and so well
it's it's just like to me it's when a
coach realizes that he's probably not
stopping the other team so what
difference does it make if he gives them
the ball at the 45 or the 15 real
I mean does that matter if they didn't
make the fourth in one with the great
play by Zach Ertz you know great play by
foals but you know the Earth's really
stretching for that yard you know so
what if they don't make it you know
honestly I don't think it's gonna make
that big a deal because you know that
Brady's going to get the ball one more
time you know it does it really matter
based on what you've seen in history I
got to tell you it was so interesting to
be in that lot in the locker room the
the the respect and the awe for Tom
Brady your friend your Michigan man your
Wolverine the respect and awe for Tom
Brady was just like it was totally off
the charts like Turney Burton just just
is like shaking his head and I mean
everybody was it was you know so I mean
if they didn't create the turnover
honestly if Brandon Graham doesn't make
that play
I mean rich could you imagine the
Patriots going down to score and and
somehow someway you know them basically
let's say it would have been you know 40
to 38
could you imagine if holes leads them on
a drive in Jake Elliott kicks whatever
it is a 49 yard field goal to win and
it's 41 40 I mean how great would that
have been I mean this was this was one
of the great games every time you think
that that you're sticking a fork in
football and nobody loves it anymore in
the ratings you're down in all this I
just you know I was in all of that game
was such great theaters well when it was
32 26 Peter you know Brockman and I we
were watching the game Steve Young
sitting right next to us
and I'll say this I don't care Steve
Young looks at us and he says give us
the final score of the game right now
we all looked at each other we said 40
39 Patriots yeah that's we said I mean
because we just that's the way these
things have always played out in a way -
and in this respect though Peter Peter
King the MQB joining us here when you're
coaches you say you're seeing that
you're having trouble stopping the other
team you do something
out whatever you can you got to pull out
all the stops yeah how about inserting
the corner back that sealed Super Bowl
xlix how about that
if you're having trouble stopping the
other team why was Malcolm Butler
sitting from start to fight I don't know
I hope you get the answer from Tom
Curren because I don't know I've
listened to Ian Rapoport who had a good
very good theory that there was multiple
things I've listened to my crease on it
and I can't really add much to what
they're saying that but there was
something rich I think the shocking
thing to me not surprising the shocking
thing is you know the Patriots only have
45 guys dressed for the game and I say
45 because and it's not that I don't
count Brian Hoyer but he's not playing
okay you know so so I'm saying they have
45 guys in the game now I assume that
Bill Belichick knew unless one of his
DBS was knocked out of the game you know
somehow and just simply could not play
anymore
that he was not playing Malcom Butler in
the regular defense my question is are
you telling me that one of your seven
inactives that day one of them any one
of them you're telling me that that guy
couldn't have helped you in this game
I'm just shocked that Bill Belichick
wasted a roster spot with Mel with
Malcolm Butler yeah and we were talking
in the first hour - is that it just
seems crazy to question any coaching
decision Bill Belichick Meg's right
Peter I mean it is but but rich think of
this I'm writing this for tomorrow okay
just imagine just imagine if the Russell
Wilson pass that Malcolm Butler
intercepts hmm at the goal line just
imagine if that pass was complete and it
was a touchdown we're talking about the
timeouts just imagine how much crap Bill
Belichick would be taking the rest of
his life for giving up 45 seconds and
handing the ball to Tom Brady at the 25
with 19 seconds to go instead of with
say 59 seconds to go or whatever it
would
I mean he would have gotten crab for
that he still would be taking it so I'm
not saying he got lucky I'm saying it
turned out to be a great call but you
know I think that if that didn't happen
just imagine that instead of going for a
third Super Bowl win in four years
they'd be going for back-to-back wins
and they get their clocks cleaned and
give up 538 yards and everybody would be
saying what genius but I'm exaggerating
a little bit sure you can still be
without any question the best
quarterback of this modern era are the
best coach of this modern era but but
the legend would have been tarnished a
bit if Malcolm Butler doesn't pick off
that football few more minutes with
Peter King in the mmq be what I'd love
to ask you to do if you don't mind cuz
I'm gonna do the same thing when I get
to the combine would you mind asking
around and what because to me this is an
underreported story did the NFL change
the way they reviewed replays for the
playoffs compared to the regular season
it seems to me the Corey Clement
touchdown in the Super Bowl would not
have stood as called during the regular
season they went back to the Dean
Blandino is in my opinion rich in my
opinion yeah that play right there said
to me that at some point and I wrote
about it I got a little bit roasted in
some corners but I told Alberto River on
to stop playing God and in my opinion I
will not be surprised knowing the way
the NFL works if Roger Goodell one day
stuck his head into our River ons office
or vice versa and and Goodell said let's
let's stick to the letter of the law
absolutely incontrovertible evidence
that a play is wrong mate I mean I would
be the one that's the worst one to me
all year is Kelvin Benjamin Buffalo at
New England's that that is an
inexcusable replay overturned correct
that is an inn
excusable horrendous overturn and that's
why I'm saying that if that was an
overturn than climate climate would have
been an overturn on that day but it
wasn't read in the playoffs I think that
they decided to say the Blandino way of
let's go stand it's called
incontrovertible evidence for the
playoffs that's what we're doing cuz
yeah I would agree totally I think
whether something happened which I think
it did but I can't prove it I don't know
it but that Cory Clement play I think on
November 15 would have been ruled
incomplete I was in time with you last
question for you is the poll question
ask it of him Chris Brockman Peter King
here on the Rich Eisen show Peter which
quarterback do you want for the long
term Kirk Cousins Nick Foles Drew Brees
Sam Bradford Case Keenum or one of the
rookies coming in all three agents with
the exception of foals Peter
we're assuming cousins will be free well
I need to ask this question first sir
I'll take I'll take foals with this
coaching staff but I think foals is like
all quarterbacks there's the vast
majority of them I think they need to be
coached in coach well and I think
they're they're the the play calling
look I mean Frank Wright drew it up Doug
Peterson quasi drew it up but he called
it and they coached him well with John
DeFilippo is there that is a great not a
good but a great offense and coaching
staff so you know look I don't know
anything about these draft guys I don't
know I really like Baker Mayfield but
that's just from watching them a few
times on TV I'm gonna say foals but it's
got to be with a gigantic asterisk and
what do you think they're gonna do with
him first blush I think they're gonna
keep them for a year and and then the
following year they either let him go in
free agency or franchise tag them and
then try to trade them just my gut
feeling
I don't know how if you're the
Philadelphia Eagles
and you have a doctor who says that it's
nine to 12 months with Carson Wentz and
nine months is five days after the
opener of the 2018 season how do you
trade Nick Foles how do you treat Nick
Foles and play chase Daniel maybe the
first six weeks of the season or pick a
guy I don't know it I think it's dumb it
defeats the purpose not all the purpose
obviously but it defeats the purpose of
trading them for trading form in the
first place I absolutely unequivocally
would not trade them unless on you know
whatever April 1st or whatever it is
unless your doctor's come to you and say
I'll put my I'll put my reputation on
the line
Carson Wentz will be ready on September
9th or whatever day it is Peter great
Chad as always we'll chat down the line
great job a great season another great
season Peter King Peter King here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience